so two times two times two times two
times two two times zero
okay two multiplied by itself five times
is thirty-two so the opposite of that is
a question what number multiplied by
itself five times gives you thirty-two
and the way you express that is that
you'd go
to the fifth
it's the fifth root and that happens to
be
two
so because in mathematics there's some
beautiful patterns there's actually a
way
that you can work out
the fifth root of very large numbers
in your head very quickly and you don't
have to use a lot of computing power
brain power so brady
if you take any double digit number you
like
and multiply it by itself five times
and you tell me that number in english
from left to right
and i write it down
i will be able to tell you what your
original number was
okay
okay okay you got you got a number yeah
is it big yeah it's big you ready 79
million wait a minute
79 million
168.
168. so your number is
38.
well yes it is it is it is okay very
good
how do i do it so quickly
i'm genius
we're gonna
[Laughter]
well obviously not i
i did it because there's a pattern in
the numbers okay so
uh it actually it's actually to do with
a
wonderful mathematician euler this is
euler's theorem i'm not actually going
to write down what euler's theorem is
i'm actually going to show you a result
from euler's theorem for
any
number a
a raised to the fifth power
is
equal to some multiple of 10 plus your
original number a
so you can get that from euler's theorem
now that's not the theorem itself but i
just want to cut the chase here so what
is let's actually do an example so let's
do 47
by the fifth power okay so 47 by the
fifth power
actually we can write it as 22 million
times 10
plus
47. so if we expand this out well a
number times 10 you put a 0 on the end
right so it goes 2 2 9
3 4 4
9 6 0
plus and if we do you know what we do in
primary school plus 47
look what you got at the end
zero plus seven
seven
so what that means is
any number multiplied by itself five
times
the last digit doesn't change
so for me to know what the last digit of
your number was
i just have to wait to hear you say it
and then i write it down
okay
the first digit
it's a bit harder the first digit you've
got to memorize
all the powers
of the tens
to the power five
so
that's one hundred thousand twenty to
the five
is
three million thirty to the five is that
forty to the five is that fifty to the
five is that sixty to the five that
eighty to the five is
uh
three
two
and 90
to the five now an interesting point
here all right is that these numbers
uh you can notice
10 1 22 33 44.
see that these numbers are all the same
because 5 6
it's the same as that number there and
the reason why is because of that if you
think about it so when
you said the number brady all right so
you said 79 million
automatically i thought 79 million
so i know that's between
30 to the power 5 and 40 to the power 5.
okay
and then you went on and did
235 000. i kind of tuned out at that
stage i wasn't really paying attention
don't take it personally i was just
waiting for you to hit the jackpot at
the end
so if you have um
if you have someone who like reads out
the number who's like an accountant or
something
or an engineer he's an engineer it just
kind of gives you a rough estimate
you're stuffed
that's still a big ask to memorize all
that
is it
doesn't it didn't take me that long
you just i think you just have a feel
for the numbers but you don't it doesn't
have to be that precise you just i mean
you just need to memorize it yeah you
just need to know that it's anything
between 3 million and 24 million you
know you don't have to be that precise
anything that's greater than 100 million
you know when i go to schools if i do
this for school kids they always pick
something in the 90s
but the 90s is so easy
because it's just anything greater than
6 billion so if they go
8 billion you just go nine
and you just wait till they say the
thing at the end the hardest ones are
actually down here down here and it's
actually hard in the transition i had
trouble quite a bit believe it or not a
lot of kids love to do 69 to the power
five
and that one was hard because it crossed
over from 77 77 million up to
1.7
billion and that was a bit hard but i
got used to it